new in theaters this weekend a house
with a clock in its walls and life
itself this is your weekend ticket great
for the entire family a house with a
clock in its walls follows The
Adventures of ten-year-old Lewis you
must live with his kimono wearing
warlock uncle Jonathan played by Jack
Black well I feel don't even know that
there are our male witches there are
there yeah what's the difference between
a warlock and a wizard good question uh
surprise surprise Jonathan's house has a
clock in its walls they don't know what
the clock does exactly but surprise
surprise again it's not good
thanks to this clock Lewis Jonathan and
Jonathan's good friend mrs. Zimmerman
played by Kate Blanchet must combine
their magical forces to save the town
from fantastic creatures and ghosts this
movie is for you if you like fantasy
novels turn movies like Harry Potter or
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events Jack Black playing alongside kids
like in School of Rock makes you lol or
you've never much cared for conventional
placements of clocks also at this
weekend life itself well I mean life
itself is always happening around us
always but this weekend life itself is
the name of a movie about life itself
Hey
are you pregnant following the romance
of college sweethearts through life we
get to witness their relationship
blossom and see the impact that they had
on the lives of the people around them
starring Olivia Wilde and Oscar Isaac
and directed by the creator of this is
us Dan Fogelman I can't wait to get my
ugly cry on this movie is for you if you
like true to life relationship dramas
you need a solid feel good cried this
weekend
or you're just a fan of life itself that
is your weekend ticket what will you see
and check back next week to see Tiffany
Haddish take on Kevin Hart in night
school
[Music]